welcome to the first Android developer
office hours of the new year are happy
new year bonne année born and all frozen
noise Yara ah felis ano nuevo and any
other how may be clutch your hunky
jumping with a dutch happy new year for
us so look at me we are Oh miss New Year
to you too as well so having you kicked
off by sea yes as you may notice we're
joined by Chris Bane's in the Android
studio today but uh because he's the
newest member of the Android developer
relations team hey welcome her servant
this hi Sparky with us hey Sparky and
here yes I'm here largely to acknowledge
my departure since I'm moving out of
Android developer relations and into
internal Google projects I'll been doing
much the same thing as I did before but
for for inward facing stuff rather than
external I hope that points out very
well I'm sure we'll still see you in the
Android seen on a ram Sparky and of
course Nick butcher as well hey Nick hi
happy new year so it's been I kicked off
the new year weird CES guess we've seen
lots and lots of new Android stories um
have you got any favorites from over
there in the London office and it seems
to be the big CES of big big phones so
lots of 1080p 5-inch 6-inch devices we
could a phone if it six inches phablet
maybe I hate that word yeah it's a long
way right Vizio is a home in the vizio
ZTE xperia sony lenovo they're all there
it seemed like 1080p is the new table
stakes resolution when you read a review
of the phone it says you know 720p
screen you get just one 1080p at 4.7
inches I'm really don't to stretch to
that five inches ya gotta wait because
previously with the 720p you kind of
have that a tablet and then phones
caught up whereas now it's kind of
tablets phones have gone 1080p
tablets haven't quite got there yet I'll
see you up the nexus 10 but most tablets
is Dylan sort of 1280 yeah fine enough
assault born this morning on the verge
that was 10 1920 x 1200 so gone past I
mean be a 7-inch so maybe that's what
the seven inches are going to set on an
attentional be 1080i I think I think
2560 is where there for tablets now what
can i say i'm spoiled young easily
in it that's a good point with the Tegra
4 a quad-core a 15 and the the new
snapdragons the s800 s600 and all those
chips coming out by in the next few
months we could definitely be seen those
high resolutions getting pushed around
hey you guys hi guys that's said I I do
have to acknowledge the Santa Claus was
very very busy hauling around next 27 to
my family haha mine too 12 definitely
max in seminar popular gift this year I
think one of my standouts from them from
CSI seen is a vizio and his mother
manufacturer seem to be backing off
there and OEM customizations and kind of
like recognizing that the stock has got
stock Android has got to a point where
it's you know a fantastic experience and
you don't need to put layers on top of
it it just slows down upgrade cycles and
so forth so for me I think that's a
wonderful site and I think we're really
rounding upon it yeah is excellent news
isn't hoping to see more about awesome
and goodbye goodbye to cupcake on the
that's the Android dashboard updated
last weekend cupcakers fallen off the
bottom I assume that means it's less
than half of point one of a percent or
something high school sorry and forty
percent of users are on ice cream
sandwich in a bug right yeah look 14 I
that's 21 on like most of that yes much
more sandwich given that given that
cupcake had some noteworthy security
problems and even the g one was
upgradeable to donut I I never wanted
anyone to support cup Kate any help so
ok some browsers and unfortunately
Matt's not here because he's Act CES
lucky guy so what's probably sleep right
now but um yeah there's a few new
announcements on GTV front as well so
the asus device and a new high sense
device i've been great yeah yeah pretty
exciting the cube looks good the asus
one looks very nice device home located
that's good your big thing is Nvidia's
project shield and if gain controller
device I think once drove call to sue
you see it said it's going to get 24
hours of HD playback video playback
that's got to be a good sign for the
Tegra 4i hope like that you know rock
you know yeah I think this is the new
28-nanometer processor architecture I
suppose in a controller you can keep a
bigger battery anyway yeah so I might be
why it's also not very nice it's not big
screen since I'm four inches on it still
being screened for a control you just
put on your hand so oh yeah it doesn't
it but you know they're just going to
use that that increased efficiency just
to give you a smaller battery and
shipping devices yeah probably it's a
good thing I guess they've all happened
the end the four plus one cause now as
well aren't they so they're having the
low-powered core which takes over when
you're not reading we're not really
taxing it and it spins at the high
performance one so yeah I think I would
like to see more focus on on battery
life absolutely um what else was it
wasn't just the icon room was my sake
just get that one ah this sorry that's
hardware right is he ESO on the android
developer that kind of on the software
side of things we had it exciting blog
post yesterday but and talking about
some new authentication steps hmm yeah
use GMS core two or ten to get against
your own back-end servers now exact
endpoints think of that i haven't delved
into it myself yet but um I'm pretty
excited about it I think yeah it will
ease the need to handle things like
usernames and passwords in your app and
still be kind of sure
you're talking T so I think this is
really real awesome yeah it's not why I
doing it but because I happen to get
used to register and login it's just
district disrupts the user flow so
anything to make up apps as soon as
possible it's always good thing is there
a demo app for that to see the flow and
stuff like that or is it just a blood
pot it's a blog post be goes through the
whole flow it's not even the gable Play
services oh I'll look it up later yeah
some bigger plus and on blocks are ya up
the log right hand ok welcome to sepi as
well from italy ah thank you very much
happy New Year to everybody Happiny yeah
and Lucas as well happy new cos okay
does anyone in the Hangout to have a
question before we jump into the 14
questions we have lined up in the
moderator today I wonder if andrew kelly
put all of them in not all but maybe a
third okay I post a question in the
moderator guys I've ran into an issue
where my app is causing a force close on
a sony xperia device and it turns out
the sony xperia framework is referring
to a resource ID which i have also also
defined in my app so it's it looks like
it's I don't know using an app resource
ID or something have you encountered
such things where device crazy fashions
yeah well I mean this is a very large
pool of resource IDs and the chances of
them crashing uh are very small but I
guess it is possible they could crash I
mean they are generated at random in the
resources are not java file right yeah
but in this case is it is for setting
the the phosphoryl thumb a drawable
which apparently Shoni is using its own
skin or or theme
whatever but still I've read a post by
Diane heck born which which takes the
the once it called the 7f the first 2i x
numbers in the resource identifiers are
4x only so is it then a buck by sony
using I don't know hardcode research I
did the fires or how did it get
generated into their framework or as
anybody encountered that with other OSS
or another that is only a building on
top of the android framework and pretty
horizon and they're not using the
reserved resource IDs for their own apps
ok be I think you can do a workaround by
using a public and ID's xml yeah and
generate your own ideas and set the ids
and the xml to be sequentially added and
i think that should do a workaround on
all devices because on the public XML
you can define ideas you want to expose
and if you want to expose them then the
system and generates a different linkage
or something i'm not sure where it is
that i just read about it a few years
ago so i think i saw a book by spies
will you say it's only happening when a
yeast actionbarsherlock into it yeah but
i don't know if that's there well that
makes me think stay with the the theme
perhaps like because because if you're
using these Sherlock themes then they
may be trying to theme some of the
attributes and if they're just trying to
alias them to underlying resources and
Sony's changed something then there's
various look posing brother as well and
then you have to move that a specific
interview
style chair with you to a value stash
v11 a resource folder and then you're I
think you're out of the loop not not
flashing notes on older Android OS
devices so I'm I'm not sure if it's if
it's actionbarsherlock specific because
of my view which it's a sony framework
resource it'sit's absolu so it could be
in their framework or could be in there
at like a ritual same in one of the reps
I don't know so yeah it it pops up with
with external surrogates that's
definitely tunic but i'm not sure if
they're this registered the real issue
you all right sounds very bad this a
resource you can use inside your
application that they're providing yeah
it's terrible for them to use a seventh
ID for it isn't it Yeah Yeah right yeah
um maybe just email me the details hello
that Diane knows about it now as well
yeah cool so we can send out to our sony
partner manager and so happens okay will
do he'll never know jewish device it was
on yeah is there new firmware on tumblr
all forward two or three to four okay
maybe it's already been reported on
fixed but yeah that this one I'm afraid
but then you still have to have
workarounds for this particular degree
case affecting like all sony devices so
now
okay that's true okay curious okay thank
you guys but I'd be good to find out the
details because he couldn't find some
time ah sorry and make an Chris live off
right come on yeah we're back we got
that little bag okay okay any other God
Oh have one present you'd hang up or
should we jump into this moderator
sounds like we're gonna jump into the
moderator you sort of already did it was
your hands question was one of our
moderator questions absolutely it's
always nice when people come in when
people who are going to ask questions in
the Hangout put them in the moderator
first though so we get a chance to
pre-read them not that I did okay uh it
looks like you've already had a look
through some of these sparkly georgette
jump on oh I could I didn't have much to
say about this first one Jamie says when
using a multi auto text view I process
the list when user selects an item by
clicking but i also want to detect new
items added manually what's not on the
list and do the same process as its one
words when user press space or
punctuation etc he goes on to say I used
on Keith listener but this only works
with Android Miami options set to
something which is annoying as a
landscape on smaller devices it fills
the screen gives a button I either want
to stop at filling the screen or not
have it be set am i doing it completely
wrong yeah I don't have a lot to
contribute on that one I don't have
experience of that particular control
but any any of you guys work with multi
auto text deal before I have but I'm
trying to work out what he's trying to
do and yeah let's skip that one and do
after I've never read fruit
but we can always come back to that one
later really i am ii always fills the
screen in landscape mode right that's
just the default behavior can I variety
though for I remember and if you'd ever
ride again use your own custom one but
yeah well here's an easy one shyvana
from Egypt says are there any news
regarding augmented reality ap is for
Android camera I know of some
third-party augmented reality api's most
of the augmented reality stacks you know
have one like Julio's got one and I
think layers got one and the wikitude
but I don't know of any actually from
Android itself the woken was last entry
in your gonna them in the developer
spacer I wouldn't expect to see sts
internet yeah put it past us at some
point in the future I mean I just sort
of you know taking them off my nose
anything had and putting on my wild
speculation hat I'm thinking that some
sort of AR would probably have to go
with Google glass otherwise what good
would it before okay maybe but maybe
they would also used to use a our
toolkit or something I mean we could
divert the entire Android engineering
team resources to building an AR library
from wanted but there's some excellent
ones out there already that many apps
and games being built on top of and
professional software so I just have a
search for it head up I our toolkit or
something it's a complex erience we tell
me the and of course there's many
different kinds of ER to write I mean
there's there's a real world stuff
overlaid on top a video but then there's
also like actually looking at codes and
specific recognized items you know so
there's there's like the Geo stuff and
then there's also the the image
processing stuff
cool see ya Andrew Kelly Zhou Bo Guagua
questioning and saying with fragments
what's the correct way to move from one
to another as in 12 to 23 24 and then
for data entry and then the fourth
fragment or pressing back you want to go
back to the start rather than going back
for the fragments so there's like a
wizard tightening the best way to do
that I'd say is each time you add a
fragment is add a bat stack ID and to
usually have no idea so I think any
string you want really and then when the
user does press back but it's prob about
to have a button actually st. finished
and then when I press finish you can
call awesome cool yeah fragment magic
yeah okay there's a method call which
takes you back to that particular ID so
you move all the fragments from the
Baxter can you go back to the original
idea you can also do it the back button
by calling or not adding at the back
stack when you add a fragment and I'm
not entirely sure if I agree with that
user flow I mean I sort of think you
know either you go with the paradigm
that says fragments don't do back stack
you know say like you're reading through
your emails if you have a navigation
pane and a detailed pain usually you
don't stick those on the back stack or
they do in which case maybe you should
go backwards through the you know that
the sequence of input dialogues or
whatever i don't i don't really agree
with changing the behavior just because
the user has completed all the input i
would usually interpret the back button
in an input scenario like that is saying
cancel you know forget it all either
meaning go back and correct the previous
page or i suppose just just wipe the
whole mess but yeah i don't know i'm not
i'm not really liking changing it just
because it's on the last page tells me
if i was going to do it was it flow I'd
use Romans wizard sample and I use
access put a lot of effort it's make me
a wizard fo that looks nice and wet
well and you can go through stage by
stage without being able to skip stages
and all that good stuff so I'm I
probably just let Roman do the work I'm
gonna grab his was a fun song for all
right + 14 not reinventing the wheel
yeah that's the kind of google com /a
/em in Europe dashing code I just wanted
to add something about what Sparky said
about the flow for the fragments and and
don't use the back stack or everything
if we want to show the user a tutorial
and we want him to go back to the main
screen of the app then that's the best
use case for not using the back stack or
our overriding the simple behavior for
the back stack for fragments yeah yeah
back does seem to be sort of the obvious
obvious control to use for closing out a
tutorial either that or it may be the
the up chevron I'd want to express it
skip button in any tutorial um yeah
that's a year too although I I don't
know I'm actually pretty okay with using
back to just closed on a tutorial I
don't I don't feel the need for a skip
button there but but I feel like if you
haven't haven't seen it it's the first
thing i see when i launched yet it feels
like back would close the app you don't
know some things behind it ya know but i
think the the best use case is what the
sparky said that back from the first
screen of the tutorial goes and puts you
back into the main screen of the app
only if you showed the user the main
baithi at first was I don't know what's
behind the tutorial right now I thought
I agree and so that so the best use kiss
to show tutorial then I'll do something
like
first screen the user will see is the
tutorial screen and instead of a skip
the home navigation will get you back to
the main screen of the app and from any
screen you're in the tutorial say you
have eight screens for the tutorial
every time you press on the home
navigation and you go back to the home
screen for the app yeah I'm fine with
about burton taking you know close this
tutorial take you back to the you know
the launching of the app i think it
should do that in fact i also would like
a skip button just because yeah it's not
obvious there's no obvious affordance to
for going back right I can see how maybe
this is a case where you want to do
different behavior for your tablet in
your phone UI your phone UI fills the
whole screen in which case maybe having
a skip one it's the obvious thing to do
but if you've got a tablet UI maybe your
tutorial is just a little inset dialogue
in which case and I just obvious that
there's an app behind there and then
back and just dismiss it that looks
sounds good well that's nice cool
alright show you guys the next fishing
the moderator ready air I'll get some
prominence in the right it's asking if
there's any pointers for implementing a
chips type you I on pre ICS devices and
are there any proper libraries available
so the chips you I guess is the UI we
use in gmail and messaging and so forth
so that as you enjoy recipients name and
then you kind of pick one from a list it
turns into a nice little box with an aim
a little avatar on that was quite a nice
doggie why decade they've understood we
meant and to that end I would say
probably look into the SMS application
mms stop get which is open source so
that's going to be your probably your
best bet and you explicitly ask about
pre ICS so wondering if thats if there's
anything there's depend on it i'm not
sure i'd have to have a look see it's
going to pendants ease on your stuff
anyone know of any other clubs
everything
there's a nice answer as well someone
knows himself is saying this but he's so
creating his own one my guess is i
wonder if there's any kind of better
sample code but i'll take a look at the
MSM no one else got any experience here
cool it looks likes on the right track
anywhere please use and also complete
text here which is what you're more than
what he needs right then any other
questions slide from the room we've got
you feel that you can you join us how do
you feel hey is that many 80s and it's
your question height okay have you
hadn't look at the mms up i have indeed
look okay what's really well the bit
misty but it works i mean its use low
power devices up o young loso news big
load rams quick but welcome reference
design devices there needs to be as
lightweight as possible and I mean this
one worked well for yeah well it sounds
like from your description sounds like
you're absolutely on the right track all
right I just saw morning sorry yeah go
to say I just going on so next question
in the moderator you saw a question in
the moderator that says that video
calendar got get instance and get year
on it it's returning 2012 if you run
android for at 12 and 20130 android 42
which is crazy um obviously have no idea
why but she definitely raised as a bug
if it is true with repro steps and more
details maybe are you running one on an
emulator and one on device and maybe the
clock is set wrong on one of them and
another on an emulator maybe but it
seems a very strange what I would have
thought we'd have heard about it if it
was always the case that the calendar
classes in Android was returning the
wrong year on for at one
anybody heard anything about that before
data hard then again if you told me that
we were missing December last year on a
bath sigh hey definitely check the bug
tracker this is from etienne and I might
actually go and try it myself because
that's just crazy if it's true he says
both were on a device oh yeah his
comments on his own thing saying better
on advice and the clock set right on the
device on both of them he ran one of the
nauseated human he may be different time
zone yeah very close to the new year
when he was doing it maybe Indiana
sounds familiar i think this is someone
we've heard from before he returns a
value that I results of subtracting 1900
from the year that contains all begins
with the instant in time represented by
this date object as interpreted in the
local timezone this is deprecated for a
good reason wait ok again thanks for the
Wreckers font so maybe actually this is
a known issue and you shouldn't be using
thing is documented in Java Docs and jdk
six is java dot but i can't see the same
documentation in the android rocks or in
do i wonder weird
comes your heart needs coffee some of
the sum of the values returned at zero
index and some natural values yeah some
fees zero indexed my remember says died
the diamond and yet risen wave them his
herbal does that impact anything else
we're inside the Hangout yeah can I send
you a bill youtube video to see for a
second I'll put it in that great chat
girlfriend yeah just like kittens or
something well done no it's question I
think it's a good it's equally efficient
okay you gotta yeah Tyson sliding in and
out yeah yeah the slamming menus to show
that you have swiping like a tutorial
yeah um what do you think about it this
is a good way to persuade users to use
the sliding menu or use the slide or
swipe feature you have seen if you have
a match which on first role of the
application they force that slide just
to show the user that it's there um
maybe our UI designer can can comment on
that can you see the video neck yeah
we're just looking it now so you have a
little hint right so yeah I'm peak is
come on baby nice action bars there I
doesn't live in it's all very smooth
anyway okay I think first of all I love
the app
I would be it is oh we have 80 enemy and
a hangout did we just talk about your
question actually yeah you did you just
did a cop who got a response though this
is the calendar belluci oh yeah it's a
hundred mode uh yeah we have no idea
we'd have to go and try and read through
it I guess sure um how do I go about
that like filing bug yeah actually you
go to be the android com and all the
steps are right there okay yeah I've
never done it before yeah he is just to
have it like a simple and test case you
can we can used to replicate it okay
yeah i was looking um because you said
check the set time on the Nexus S and I
don't know where to see potentially the
date then the date set to current date
january nine of this year oh you not
sure what ya said to well i would
believe it set to the current year but
there's nothing to to suggest that it's
if you go to 20 settings so today I'm
special checking before rising on little
bug ya date and time you know how much I
hope this is gonna say twenty nineteen
ninety-two this range I guess my date
was set to 2012 that's it thank you guys
oh it could have something to do with I
haven't um I took the sim card out and
placed it into my nexus 4 because I just
got it so that could be the issue it's
not what precise looks like that I
because of the sim card being removed
Thank You first at the right day and
month but not the right here yeah but if
you have if you said that if you check
the
automatic automatic and network update
I'm and you log into a Wi-Fi or
something then it goes to the time
servers and updates the according to the
time zone yeah i think i'm testing on a
device that's without a sim card so it's
kind of not really a real scenario mom
so I guess I shoulders counter for that
all right oh that's your your sis
question because we can't sorry so your
question was basically if it called
teach you some kind of animation to hint
at how you interact yes so we're good a
vision envision like showing that like
on some first run or but basically on
two occasions on first run because we're
going to do a UI change and if we want
and the example i posted was a specific
for swiping but i'm talking generally on
all the swiping double tapping you name
it whatever gesture you want us to to do
on your app i'm talking about making a
simple 22 seconds demo of the gesture
and showing that to to the user as here
you can click on me in here you can
scratch me here you can kick me I don't
know whatever yeah Jimmy I'm okay with
using some kind of animation as an
affordance essentially like to kind of
say this is how you interact with me I
think what you need to be wary of is
getting annoying so like you know
showing it every time I become annoying
I kind has also of the YouTube
application for example when they move
to sliding drawer and similar to this
application that used to kind of open
with that and then the main UI would
fold into tented it and we played around
some iterations that and i think it was
decided that it was just unnecessary
that the sliding in menus becoming
and a well-known pattern now and that it
was unnecessary kind of like a road bump
to go over in order to get to what you
really wanted which was the content I
think as these these interactions become
more and more popular you know some of
the top applications out there are using
it like YouTube G Plus Facebook things
like this using these kind of sliding
menus and somewhat bezel swipe some
without that people are getting used to
it and yeah it becomes unnecessary but
yeah generally if you have a nun you
know gestures are hard that there aren't
any natural kind of way to enter that is
available that you do need to provide
some either some tutorial or some some
way to bootstrap the users mental model
ready so young core that as long as you
kind of try to you know only show it at
first a couple of times or something
like that some apps basically use
overlay on the layout with arrows and
pointers and text and i think i prefer
the this way that the user sees the the
real interaction with the UI instead of
an image showing with texts and stuff
Ivy Tech ends on the interaction and so
for something where you have to swipe is
showing the user better and it's a good
library showcase of you which is based
off the launchers playing in yeah yeah
yeah and so that's worrying about my
buttons and Timmy have to click so yeah
I mean I I personally like sharing the
user small interactions and so in some
might seem impersonal sort open source
libraries are right I always add an easy
way for the developer to show a demo and
say yeah I passing hope you this is
actually can you hear me yeah this is
actually one of the reasons i don't like
I'm not entirely convinced about this
pattern are because it leads to trial
and error in general like you have to
like suppose that the letter like lots
of top apps using it but then you always
wonder if it's there or not ah so we'll
always have to do so
thing like this show the user that it's
there that you do it so this is one of
one of the reasons I didn't like the the
menu button approach from previous
Android uses because some apps just the
hardware button I mean like a Maps just
didn't couldn't have it right so you
have to try to see if there's something
there and for any pattern that you have
to try to see if it's there it's just I
don't know it's a sign that there's
something that needs to be improved
either like I standard hand that it's
there like the app menu it's the
three-dot thing it's there you know you
click you see something if it's not
there there's no option uh but with
sliding menus you have to try or you
have to give a hint it's just a sign
that there's something that it's not
like I don't know ready yet I don't know
on your action barking on the top you
can say that if you have an app error or
maybe a change of the home logo then
they have a sliding menu but yeah I mean
maybe maybe if we changed the icon or
indicated it's just that yeah I think
it's abusing the the standard behavior
because right now it's going up in the
hierarchy right oh and I mean you you
might argue that uh sliding in menu is
the upper or the top-level node in your
hierarchy but way it's not really is it
like nobody I've started
other than when people go sliding menu
from the left and from the right yeah
I'm what drinking doesn't the design
site say that the slide and men you can
only be at the top level yeah it's like
an activity group of some sort because
you can refer to it as the main holder
for all the as the root holder for all
the other actions you can do on on your
application yeah and the other thing I
kind of dislike about it is when you
have such a big space for options I
think people who tend to like overload
in terms of like uh options so you just
have too many nodes you don't hierarchy
just because you have space for it right
and you see if you think see things like
Facebook like it has like huge thing
like Google+ has like uses it in a kind
of a smarter way because it uses the
space for showing more notifications so
that's fine but let steel is tempting
because you have this huge vertical
infinite vertical space for adding
options and in the case of mobile apps I
don't think that's a good thing to like
to do so I don't know constraints are
good thing in a mobile are in general I
think so oh yeah we dropped else we
might miss some of the conversation but
we're by now and I think two things only
touch to that firstly I think it's a the
gesture is kind of like a power user
same that's how I think that I think you
need to have some on-screen affordance
that you're saying that you don't you
can't have this kind of you have to try
and see I think you need to have some
on-screen forward and so our preference
would be to use the app carrot to
disclose it that's our guidelines and
some people use the burger menu which is
gaining some traction as well but yeah I
all very much see the bezel swipe and
all the swiping is a secondary way of
launching and so in that way I'm not so
bored if people don't know about it
because it's more about you know once
you hit the menu that the primary
opening in the butt
and you see it slide out that is your
hint that is your animation right that's
the cue that this thing moves that way
and if you swipe it and discover it that
you can do it with your finger rather
than hitting the button that's like a
power user bonus in a way as long as
there is one obvious on-screen button
which is like the teapot way to open I
think that's the most important and the
second thing I would say like I was
going to say about the dumping ground
I'm very for fergie the sliding menu
sliding menu just used for navigation I
see it as a you know an alternative to
like the drop-down navigation might see
on google maps or you know if there's
more tax and you might want to have on
screen i see as a direct replacement for
that i'd rather not see it combined with
actions so like you know some people
start putting extra things in there and
i think in a way g pluses notifications
almost fall into that bucket for me that
i'd rather see it just about navigation
thing rather than trying to you know oh
I've got some extra space I'll dump some
extra stuff in there yeah I group I
think I'd prefer the Google Plus version
showed just your unread notifications
rather than all of them and then you can
click on him at notification he'll take
you to a list so that from that would be
the way I'd do if I give I was the and
the teasing teasing who was aside empty
space is important for layout but it's
going back to what you said about
dumping ground the Curie ups an app
developer she lets up the app developer
to make their app as cognitively easy to
use as possible so you should design
your app so it has you know what other
option yeah well structure yeah free or
for all or less main section to your app
and the user can then delve deeper if
they want to so that's up to the app
developer to do that just if the problem
is when you get to at like Facebook and
Google+ there's such huge app so they're
basically like an OS in a way right they
offer so many functions there are
messaging there's like news feeds as
photos this community's is so much going
on right there's a reason why Facebook
is kind of splitting their app in two
different functions right the camera
messenger and all that and I think
that's probably the right approach I
wouldn't do like this huge thing in one
place what I've got from facebook is
that the reason they got several apps is
so they can test stuff out on users so
messenger all the stuff that's in
messenger has been back for tea to the
Facebook app so it's the same code base
now in the Facebook the actual face book
out the messages as is the messenger and
Sam the sort of camera stuff so I do
agree view iving with Facebook that they
they've cut they have overloaded action
the own sliding menu and that they have
got all these separate sections but they
label layers right you can go back
within this lighting menu right yeah but
they've also got say you got groups and
then you've got sub list of your groups
whereas familiar should be just one
group whites and what you can click and
then delve in and tell you okay maybe we
should take one from the G+ stream now
that instead of from the hangout or the
moderator yeah alessandra capra is
asking I've made an application which is
a music quiz nice and it requires
registration from the user with username
and password and of the details should I
provide a privacy policy and the upper
teeth yes you should our caliper
distribution agreement in Section 4 4.3
says that if users are providing you or
your product with access to user name
details product email addresses personal
information then you must make the users
aware that the information will be
available to your product and you must
provide legally adequate privacy notice
and protection for those users so if you
don't put a privacy policy in and you
are requesting personal details then it
may be grounds to get your application
suspended from the place you'll be
violating the DDA's even so definitely
please do put a privacy policy in if
you're requesting personal information
also there's a slot in the developer
console at the bottom of your store
listing where you can link to your
privacy policy online so users can see
it before they've gotten downloaded the
application installed it and giving you
some of their details because you may be
getting some details off the handset
automatics me so it's quite good if you
can put the link into the privacy pond
you know that the new the latest version
2 of the publisher site doesn't let you
publish your app until you be that
cutter privacy policy or explicitly told
the system that you're not going to have
one so it became mandatory to do decide
one way or the other in the high
dispersion hopefully that answers your
question Alice Sun girl that's like she
said he's got a question you got a
question or is he on a phone call
there's no question you Sammy yes thank
you okay well I have a question about
the in-app billing the version number
three and especially about the local
caching okay I would like to understand
how this local caching work if the local
caching mean that the information about
the purchases are writing inside some
database or inside some other protection
mode because in the documentation I
didn't find nothing about that the
questions is because I want to
understand what happened exactly when
for example an accuser buy some item
using the in-app system and after we
make the reef armed to the users for any
reason and I want to now like to know if
the local caching would take it in count
that the purchase has been refunded and
then we'll be not useful anymore for the
application how do you mean refunded
images I mean for example that the user
write to us and ask for the refund not
that he can make the refunding stuff
because this is not possible as
everybody i can write my definite
billing API it has a concept of
refunding side balcony cuz I've ever
known I agree so Jack refund an in-app
billing item then they still own it
you've just given their money back
so so when I will get i will use the
method get purchases the the purchases
would be not refreshing in the local I
story no I think the user will still own
that item but they purchased at heaven
but I will have a look just in case the
other thing about that she has answered
documentation I didn't to find any
useful about this yeah I don't think
cashing changes anything here I think
even without the caching if you refresh
it from the survey will still say yes
the user does purchase dislikes and
identity is it back like I say out it
the in-app purchase API has any concept
of refund a slightly country to that the
documentation does say that in that
building doesn't allow users to request
refunds but if you refund them through
google checkout our Google Play receives
a refund notification from check out and
sent a refund notification to the
application oh no it's your case as long
as the device is connected to the
network the cash the local cache will be
updated straight away your application
receive the refund education that's very
good and do you know each other if the
local caching is maintained it by
Sandler sequel like database or anyway I
don't know how to keep the data okay
because I'm thinking if if we have just
to come but I canister the LVL license
crackers or we have also to combat the
agonies to the people that we try to
write some Rove inside the database you
know if it is a day space my guess is
it's quite well encrypted I doubt
there's anything on that it's easy to
attack my you know um
I wouldn't be worried about our side of
it I just put a link in the chat window
as well to handle any refunds and that
links up and shows you be a flow
wouldn't exactly what exactly is the
reason why did I nap items either not
refundable why why Google this fire
because the user may have already spent
it they may be buying calling credit
things like that out on your in-app
billing and then they may make a phone
call and then refund the cricket if we
had a 15-minute refund window they could
totally abuse that for in-app billing
because we don't know what they're just
purchased from me and whether if they
can continue in the first 15 minutes and
then we found it they could just
continue doing that and have infinite
free service on yon your service correct
so yeah I mean I've developed as
expected gratifications for that first
15 minutes but in that melon we don't
know what you've just solved so it's not
reasonable cool I've got 10 minutes ago
you go back to the moderator and pick of
any more bitches he was a physical
tomorrow at times you know that's gone
all right
Davis and then who says I'm working on
improving the testing of my apps right
now I test on a few devices that run
using monkey I started adding some unit
tests as well but not sure how far to go
of them are there any other good testing
methods is but how do you test bank
aster see this isn't a very good answer
but we didn't search well we I did I
spent a lot of time using it so that was
my main test and I used it all hell of a
lot so but in terms of funnel test in
there wasn't a whole lot done and just
kills me by myself and it was just kind
of I'd spent more time developing their
test my ass was I'm sorry no that's
about it really we dig a bit of monkey
stuff because it's easy and cheap to do
and unit tests in your test is quite
hard wait it's hard to do anyway but you
can only really do proper unit testing
arms sort of utility classes because
their duties to do you want to start
doing UI testing it comes very hard very
quickly mm-hmm so there's the UI
Automator talk now which has been
launched which is an interesting tool it
also helps you make sure you add all
your content descriptions and stuff
which is a good thing and I have any
other advice on testing tools I know you
it's you're a fan of these no no I might
as well i'm currently writing an app
using a network and it needs a server
and I'm kind of how you say it depending
on that server and so and so i'm not
using robo or what's a great we are
watching itss little you can use unit
testing a lot but i am not into a user
interface automatic testing yet for this
a yeah there's a services out there as
well test Royd other such cloud services
where you can record scripts and send
them up and get on the results back
again
if it's a personal project I test on the
HTC Desire my nexus 4 7 and 10 if it
works on those I just put it out there
along with a link to the bug tracker
hope that people file bugs if I make you
buy did everyone see the blog post ago
Android developers saying if you got an
exit 10 or other hi res device you can
call a cup of adb commands and you can
emulate well pretty much any device
specification in terms of display yeah
basically if you only the highest
resolution devices available and you can
test every single resolution free handy
no it's not just releases tenants for
whatever the highest resolution devices
at any time but the Nexus devices the
nexus 7 engine to run the same adb
commands the motorola xoom did as well
i'm not sure if there's yet i've never
tried on a nexus 4 I guess it does as
well Mon yeah that you can set the
resolution to anything smaller than that
imagine the native resolution you can
set the screen sizes Lansing can change
um just normal large extra large
obsolete once upon a time didn't it
require root deems that command your
version back ydp but I ebay run spoilers
don't know me not a TV but specifically
the the display emulation I have a
question if you guys played around with
the overdraw it's part of the in a
against them yeah jellied newest jelly
bean puted developer settings yeah I
drop weight once it's really pretty
quickly like interesting you leave it on
for 10 lap two doing yeah I noticed
you're a lot too I think selective app
to debug but you can't select any app
it's only a certain list of apps anyway
I true I turned it on and I was noticing
it was showing me displaying the
overdraw but to disable it
I turned it off and it looked like he
was still displaying on not only the app
I set but some other apps the only way
to get rid of it was to turn off the
device not and then they basically the
setting if you have I withdraw and turn
on it will be cash on that start up so
you'll just have to kill the app Marie
started oh okay I didn't know that yeah
you could just turn the setting off and
then no and it's on put for the whole
device you can't you don't turn it on
for particular app you turn on for the
device and if it's not working for
certain apps it's because they're not
using the hardware and acceleration
rendering framework and they must
explicitly turning it off somehow Oh
turning off so that when the only time
you wouldn't see the overdraw stuff yeah
you need to just an kill the apt n it on
funding opportunity then it off kill gap
again and you good gotcha yeah I mean I
was just doing a hard boot or reboot
yeah what's very to it as well I'm
wondering if maybe there was some
misunderstanding on what the what the
set up for debugging setting the sport I
mean I assume that was more just for
connecting up to an ADB debugger when
you when you're on the device and I have
you have you I've never actually used
that setting if you guys used it in the
manifest I think the improbable on and
off no there's a thing in the people yes
which app is going to be debugged notice
for them yeah I'm not easy I mean I
don't think that's for targeting right I
like I don't think it's for targeting
these these on device Diagnostics I
think that's for specifically what
remote what the remote debugger is going
to attach to on your device like you're
specifically trying to debug and nap
your writing I assume yeah like my ID
focuses no debug applications set but
you can choose only from a small list of
applications guessing apps that have an
Virgie bugaboo equals true in the
manifest oh that's probably true because
my the album working on is debug true so
so lets you debug apps that you haven't
written you
find me possibly but I don't know not
something right man someone fine what
open source guy to like it yeah i'm
looking at since you the thoughts oh i
just had a question um i know from
reading on a lot of different blogs
thanks to say that the mms SMS content
provider is not really open source or
it's not really hopefully also admitted
yet um yeah so if it's not if you can't
really rely on that being a way to grab
things look like a mms or SMS saved on
your phone is there an alternative or is
that sort of the only way to go about it
correct okay and I'd like help it's okay
men today the ice for sorry for SMS
analysis document api's for the kind of
incoming and stuff so you can register
for the incoming ones and focus those
but as for the actual content provider
that it's much like hardly used to be
pre ICS they're undocumented but they're
in the code so you know yeah using
missing ya know i'm using at my own risk
i'm wondering like frequently is that
kind of get updated i heard like the
paths of the mms SMS DB is different on
different devices and i'm a fest
helpline right it's not documented so it
could and probably has changed in fact
shuddering crystallization so how that
manufacturers can change that that path
if I wish to add phase changes not yeah
so the only way to really feel
comfortable about using it is to test it
on a lot of different manufacturers
absolutely yeah yeah reading you SMS is
coming in just start from the current
time and build up your SMS from from now
but try to read all the previous SMS is
and do things with those then it's not a
happy place to be yeah I'm wondering is
there way to like emulate different
manufacturer phones no no yep no I mean
some start going to buy a budget-busting
online service
but Samsung developer what's it called
I'm Justin sometimes I forget you can
use devices they're online and check
them out that's a light kiss droid yeah
you try it on toast droid can access the
song devices okay but yeah I mean you
may test it on one device and then a
firmware update with a pilot advice and
it changes unless happen it's gonna be a
tricky thing to maintain kind of scary
yes yeah I would try and avoid the need
to keep I read all the previous SMS is
impossible ok we just out of time so if
there's any burning questions that it
would like to ask right now well I have
either burn a question for a friend
which raised the question the moderator
he's trying to achieve something like
airplay on Android where he wants to
play audio from his device on all mike
surveys is simply implemented in himself
so like a bluetooth standard which kind
of overrides all your output to any
device listening on bluetooth as well is
there any the way or indication or do
does anybody know about initiatives
about playing by a Wi-Fi direct or
internal question so you want to
redirect all sound up away from the
phone to another audio sync yeah damn
you can do that via an app yeah you can
do you using the bluetooth headsets yeah
basically headset so I would look at the
bluetooth codons you'll spin on that but
you've already find there's something
securing that yeah yeah I'm jellybean
you cannot rear out all the audio but
you can if you switch your your phone to
mode in communication then it will think
you're in a call so basically all the
input and output voices or audio will go
through the headset
okay yeah i was still but still it needs
to be he wants to redirect the audio
show yeah i have to resign audio fire
yeah yeah but midnight after us we won't
start i'm looking this awesome since
give it its cool yep is it al and I am
he's called bubble DNA is bubble doing
so have a look at that chronic the sauce
because that does pretty much what
you're asking I use the custom media
player right these are a media plan yeah
they do that they deal the network stuff
as well so yeah that's all right brief
great man Chris thanks well thanks for
joining us everyone and we will see you
same time next week so just close by
guys here I 2013